the EU is ready to shed light on
controversial tax practices although tax
competition between member states can't
be fully avoided EU finance ministers
agreed that why the cooperation is
needed to put an end to so-called
sweetheart deals recent reports suggest
that some large companies have been
granted favorable tax arrangements in a
number of member states by agreeing on
this directive the EU is showing the way
who had companies larger ones normally
that paid very little or no taxes at all
in the European Union a cross-border
firm pays around thirty percent less tax
than a company active in just one
country this is done via profit shifting
and it allows money to be transferred
between the different parts of a company
a welcome move in these times of
austerity the measure will increase
transparency and help clamp down on
corporate tax avoidance and tax evasion
inside the EU a revolution revolution
tax transparency efficiency and fairness
this agreement means an end to obscure
tax agreements between companies and
authorities which can facilitate tax
abuse it means more openness and
cooperation between member states EU
finance ministers efforts to boost
transparency in international tax
markets echo similar ongoing work at the
OECD and a TG 20
you